passons maintenant à l'actualité en
france le président directeur général du
groupe air france christian blanc a
présenté cet après midi aux partenaires
sociaux le profil du nouveau groupe avec
pour 1997 la création d'une nouvelle
compagnie antoine cormery aux commandes
du groupe air france christian blanc
établi un plan de vol à trois ans et à
l'atterrissage en 1997 le ciel français
ne sera plus le même qu'aujourd'hui le
1er janvier 97 une nouvelle compagnie
française spécialisée sur les vols
européens va voir le jour résultat de la
fusion d'air inter et des activités
européennes d'air france une compagnie
dont le nom n'est pas encore connu et
qui emploiera quinze mille personnes
les vols long courrier vers l'étranger
seront eux toujours assuré par air
france ce projet marché de l et al arich
et enrichit sa connaissance du marché
significative sur le marché
international d'ici 1997 et l'inter
devra donc travailler à améliorer sa
productivité et continuer à se
développer sur les lignes européennes
vers l'espagne et progressivement vers
la grande bretagne
car le monopole sur les lignes
françaises est de plus en plus battu en
brèche
au total il aura fallu trois longues
heures au président du groupe air france
pour dévoiler ses projets d'avenir aux
syndicats des deux compagnies
on va annoncer dès ce soir dès demain
matin à des milliers de personnes qu'ils
soient personnels navigants qu'ils
soient personnels au sol que dans 28
mois ils vont changer d'entreprise sans
avoir aucune garantie sur les conditions
sociales sans avoir aucune garantie sur
l'ouverture de négociations sans avoir
aucune garantie sur les objectifs et la
pérennité de ses activités
une chose est sûr c'est qu'il faudra
beaucoup de tact et de doigté au pilote
christian blanc pour négocier ce virage
stratégique sans provoquer de
turbulences au sein de son équipage